folks jodarossa here what do we got
coming up we got shows in houston texas
on the 19th and 22nd of may we got shows
in austin texas on the 20th and 21st of
may
uh we got the punch line coming up in
san francisco in july and then in
september i'll be coming through to
somerville in the great new england area
of the united states of america uh
some of those tickets are available now
others aren't the ones that are
available you can get at
joedorosainfo.com
as i say this to you go and do that
please the other tickets will be
available soon enough my apologies
uh fort collins in denver is not
happening the club got the dates wrong
and something went sideways so that was
out of my hands and i apologize i'll try
to make it up to all of you as soon as
possible
in the meantime if you're in new york
city come to joey roses all info there
joeyrosesnyc.com we're open tuesday
through sunday full bar and delicious
sandwiches thank you
what's up taste buddies uh this week i
will be in new york city at the beacon
theater on saturday may 14th in just a
few days and then the next week after
that you can catch me in san diego at
the majestic theater on may 21st and
sunday night may 22nd in los angeles for
the first time at the wilton theater all
tickets available at savocanocomedy.com
so is taste buds merch my merch even hey
bay merch check my website out i'll see
you guys soon taste buds they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
howdy folks welcome to t-a-s-t-e
bunts
b-a-t-t-l-e b-u-d-s buds
right now
but i appreciate the i tried man i
wanted it i wanted to deliver for you i
appreciate the effort thank you as you
can see
by the fact that brian and i are wearing
um
outer shirts different outer shirts it
must be a week later that it's a week
has gone by and we're doing a new
episode you still haven't watched the
two copies of death game that we love
believe they're still sitting here
that damn maid man i was so excited to
bring this to you
and to bring this to you i mean i'm more
excited that you ordered it when we have
this but i can't wait for you to watch
the ending uh i'm excited that you
brought it to me i mean i
that was a that was a friendship jumping
up another run yeah i think so oh man
that was caught that on camera that was
wild like wild synergy yeah because not
a lot of people know about death game no
not what he does
uh today's today's battle is chicken
versus steak i'm taking steak uh q is
taking chicken but before we do that
we wanted to just take a trip down
memory lane memory lane here uh as you
know q i usually host this show with
none other than sal volcano i'm familiar
with the man
an old a lifelong friend of yours oh my
god i've known him since he was 14 years
old so that's wild right yeah it's
pretty wild i've known sal
probably only six years
okay good success not even six years
probably less than that but anyway my
point is is a handful of years compared
to your
uh your your tenure with demand yeah the
uh
i would be
i i would say i would be uh uh out of
step
to try to convince you
to speak against him
in any way yeah that's gonna be that's
gonna be rough right uh you know he's my
he's like the love of my life yeah yeah
that said
yeah i mean i will say this he's
coasting a lot on uh
like um
first 10 years of friendship sal
i will say that he is he is coasting a
lot on that
[Music]
don't get me wrong i love modern day sal
uh but he's coasting a bit a little bit
of a coast yeah he used to be a
bartender used to be the free drinks it
used to be
you know what i mean it used to be like
the hanging out we were you know that
would go a long way it went a long way
yeah i mean so that's what i just said
is about as bad as i can get when bad
mouthing sounds you're making me
question my friendship with him now what
do you mean i'm kidding oh no i was only
joking i know you were
this guy's the nicest guy on earth
that's not true the uh
my point is is i would be i'd be on as i
said out of step to try to get you to
say anything negative about cell uh most
people will be out of step trying to get
me to say anything negative about sal
however
we can agree on one thing oh you and i
yeah and it's a negative against sal
okay
he's always wrong on the show
he almost always
uh you and i agree on almost every one
of my
choices
there's no reward in that though because
um
you and i like if we went down 10 right
now we would agree on the first six and
then we'd hit one that we disagree and
then you'd completely turn on me as if
we didn't just agree on the previous i
won't do that i promise you are you sure
because
we've had this conversation without the
cameras before and and i've and i
validated choice after choice and the
second i hit a stone
no no no no turn on really hard i won't
do i won't do that i won't do that the
uh
pip do you have a uh can you pull up the
the history of the battles
i'm finding the longer record
the uh cause i don't even you know what
you could even go to our playlist
scroll from the bottom because i
remember who picked what weren't you
supposed to revisit back to the future
part three
oh god this is what we should have
argued today but you you promised me you
would go back and revisit it you said
you never even saw it you said you saw
the [ __ ] trailer
no no i said i never saw it when it came
out oh okay okay uh i own it yeah and
the first time i really sat and watched
it straight through was when i bought my
mom bought me the blu-ray set for
christmas oh so relatively recently
it's probably still probably 10 years
ago oh i think you should revisit it
it's such a fun round it's a terrible
way i hate it
i still catch it on you know
what is
happening we're gonna look at the uh
list of we're gonna go real quick down
there go to rosa info.com that's my
website
pimp just go to the page where you're
dropping on that go to the no press page
and then just click on playlists
yeah and oh so then when you hit full up
oh it makes you watch one
okay all right so let's start at the
bottom
first episode
ready yeah chips ahoy versus oreos chips
ahoy
sal wrong it's all wrong idiot thinks
oreos are better he's an idiot bad
chocolate
cinnamon raisin bagel versus everything
bagel well i think you went for cinnamon
bagel right this is this is the one you
turned on this is why i remember it oh
we disagreed on this one yeah cause i
like the i love the cinnamon raisin
but there's something about an
everything bagel all right yeah i mean
this is the one you turned on here's
south talking about the cinnamon raisin
it's like it shouldn't even happen i
love cinnamon yeah and i'll tell you
what if they're warm
don't even bring me the everything you
bring me the cinnamon raisin a warm
cinnamon raisin will destroy almost
anything thank you thank you doritos
versus compost
uh
that's doritos
yeah combos is like one of my childhoods
of course i i need things gift wraps
give me the [ __ ] doritos
apple pie versus peach pie uh
i like apple pie of course you do
because you're sane yeah yeah yeah all
right
chipwich versus traditional ice cream
sandwich we might differ on this one uh
chipwich versus traditional i'll
probably yeah we do disagree because you
like traditional right yeah yeah i like
chipwich pancakes versus waffles
i'm a pancake of course you are yes
his choices make me sick
yeah
i sometimes like when i've done this
show with him i feel he doesn't believe
the choices even like like like he will
sometimes just be i like obtuse
i think
you know what i'm going to say it go
ahead i think he picks what he thinks
the fans will like oh i know that's for
a fact you don't you're really realizing
that now
no i'm not saying he's a frontrunner but
i will say
he likes to be liked he's he's the kid
asking about the extra credit yeah a
little bit a little bit yeah
all right really savaging sally yeah
yeah
i know derosa you had something to say
about sal the last episode oh okay
so he does this thing every time when we
put the polls up right yeah where he
goes
like we'll go okay we're doing
after we talk about it for an hour and
we finally narrow in on a battle i'll go
all right so we're doing death game
versus death game we decided on that
right that's the battle let's just do it
we both agree let's just do it i'll be
like
okay okay uh
i just i wonder if and i go don't stop
just let's just do it it's a good battle
let's just do it okay then we'll go to
put the polls out yeah it'll go
should i say
best death game this is should i say
better death i'll go i don't [ __ ]
care just just put it out yeah
we're supposed to start recording 90
minutes ago yeah please like i want to
eat dinner tonight right yeah so so i'll
do that right
i always break his balls about it i
always give him he he's particular yes
yes and he think he is he analyzes right
and as he gets older
that ramps up
great so we have that to look forward to
it's gonna get worse but i always bust
the stones about it right yeah
but look at what he produces though i
mean the guys
of course
he's making one of the best tv shows in
my opinion ever made
so you can't argue with the guy's output
no listen i uh i agree that the game
show is very good
what's it called again the industry haze
what the what the hell is it called
industry hazel the one with the the lady
hosting it what's that game show called
oh [ __ ] you got a pigeon all right hey
look at that uh misery index misery
index yeah there you go yeah yeah that's
not coming back so i don't know i'm just
trying to make a joke anyway
industry hayes
so so but so anyway so i always give
them grief about the the you know and
i'll always be like is anything ever
easy can we just put the pull you know
yeah it's
all in good fun sure of course which i
feel like i have to say because you're a
nice guy i feel like you you yeah yeah
anyway but anyway it's all in good fun
so today
i'm like i text you and i go do do you
have anything you want to battle you're
like buddy i'm there for you
i'm there to help yeah whatever you want
to do let's just do it right like oh how
about weed versus alcohol rematch steak
versus chicken you go i love it i go
this is so easy this is incredible right
and i go and pimp goes you got to ask
sal to tweet out the battles because he
always tweets out the polls okay i go
this is going to be the easiest tweet
after polls ever ever yeah it's done
ever
i text him hold on let me get
yeah the uh
well it's his show he cares more
but i'm just here to chill you don't
need to defend let me just let me just
trash i mean let me just try i know
you're not telling me this stuff i've
made a tv show with a guy for 10 years i
i know what it's like
i navigate this on a level you don't
even know right like this is not what
you're talking about to me is nothing
i texted the battles
can i send you the battles you tweet him
out he goes yeah no problem
uh yeah right i go thank you battles
weed versus alcohol rematch chicken
versus steak
he writes back cool
you guys aiming for three because i only
sent him two battles right
so he's like what happened to that third
episode i thought you were gonna do
right
so then he goes
was weed versus alcohol close originally
[Music]
do you want me to mention in the poll
that it's a rematch i probably should
right
yeah chicken versus steak nothing
specific
like jesus christ dude
yes please mention that it's a rematch
it's just a good battle to do with q
uh it'll be fun
yes chicken versus steak just that
the third episode is going to be a theme
episode so we don't need a poll for that
one okay want me to post now
what do you mean a theme episode
i write back yes please post now thank
you a theme app isn't a battle and i was
just like when i'm texting him
he's like wait hold on a second he he
this is this is this is sal's process
man it's his process but it's good
because i'm just for me just and this
isn't even me defending it like i've
just given you a peek of like like it
allows me to go in the opposite
direction where i'm able to be the guy
that's like
whatever dude
because i have we're a team like so that
part of the team is covered right and
you know sometimes and and working with
sal is good because like he's
he
loves and respects me so like he's
willing to roll those dice on me
so he gives
like it's not like this is you don't
know how to do a [ __ ] talk at all
well this is going sideways this was
supposed to be a segment called why okay
okay wrong okay okay you're right you're
really worried
that's really funny let's do it
you're talking about it
i'll tell you a story i'll trash out
i'll try this out okay um yeah okay i
got it all right so we were we were we
were [ __ ] wrapping the last episode
of of season nine from practical jokers
right long [ __ ] season we started in
2019 big things happen right in the
season you know we you know we were not
we're in a uh you know we had to save
the show but the crew came back every it
was this new dynamic we had to learn to
work with each other in new ways and
stuff like that went great and to the
last day of shooting the last shot of
shooting
um
[Music]
is and sal is go doing that process
about a joke right a siskel and ebert
joke um because we were sitting in a
movie theater and he's like are people
going to know cisco and ebert is it
still valid and i'm like yeah don't
worry about it don't worry about it and
uh and then he's like and then he's like
calls casey over like will people
understand he's asking a a young crew
member do you know who's he's doing all
the the stuff because he wants to uh am
i gonna all right
so you know and i so i go like this i go
like this i go listen to me i'll say
whatever the line you want i just want
to get out there and start drinking with
the [ __ ] crew to rap this season
right and you heard from two stories up
the crew go
hey
right and then at the bar
that night and sal was at the bar it's
not like he wrapped and then went home
we all went out drinking the crew left
south but like so many people were like
dude we were so happy when you said that
because we just wanted to get the [ __ ]
out of there they're like we just
everybody like half the crew is at the
bar already like they cut loose to
people so funny so so you know um
by the way where was all this when you
guys see the reason i wanted to do this
segment why is sal always wrong is
because when i wasn't there you guys did
derozan versus the stefano oh yeah and
the talk about me yeah
was so it's you're telling me i didn't
defend
how much i love you you had to say
several times
as team derosa defender yeah i know it
doesn't sound like i'm defending him
right now but i am but i am but so i'm
saying this is what i wanted to do now
it's down
to break the balls back because now he's
not got it got it all right well now it
just looks like i'm a guy
drawing my co-host
documentary you were on camera saying
sal uh didn't bring enough jamison and
then he always cuts the riders short
oh that's that is true he will he will
like so we'll do a tour where it's like
[ __ ] all right yeah this [ __ ]
south this [ __ ] guy right we're
selling out madison square garden we're
doing [ __ ] arenas like we're doing
all these big places right and the
writer is like
seven beers and and like a bread and ham
like that's what it is and he will
without a without fail
twice a tour ask for the rider and just
start cutting things because he will
decide that nobody opened the wonder
bread so so why am i paying for wonder
bread and i'm like what the [ __ ] you
talking about like we just sold that msg
give us a [ __ ] how much has won the
bread right and he'll do that and he'll
cut the beers down from like
12 beers to six people don't drink that
they go to waste and he'll do it every
time and then i'll be backstage and i'll
be like oh i want a sandwich and a beer
and like it's not there because the
other thing that sal does
the other [ __ ] and i know and i know
it sounds like i'm i know i'm supposed
to be defending what the [ __ ] you want
me to say is is he also invites
i never have any guests i i do not
invite people to my shows i don't want
to deal with it i don't want to deal
with the tickets i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
embarrassed by my own i don't want
people to see me on stage like sal
keeps in touch with everybody he's
friends with everybody uh he will invite
like locus sal's guests he's got third
cousins in every [ __ ] state in the
land and then so the six beers that sal
cuts down
gone like that and if i want a beer i
gotta ask the [ __ ] tour manager can
they get me a beer then they gotta go
all the way up to the front of the house
to get more beers to bring it back and
then i'm done that happens every every
single [ __ ] time and that's let me
tell you something that's inconsiderate
how about that for a trash talk on sale
there you go all right all right there
you go that's what i'm asking for over
here jesus christ
the uh let's go back to some more
battles now we're in the spirit vanilla
ice cream versus chocolate ice cream
uh
vanilla ah we disagree there okay no
problem wendy's versus mcdonald's i'm a
wendy's guy i know you're mcdonald's we
disagree there it comes down to the
fries right with you yeah but that was
also i have to specify with that battle
that battle was for the all-time
greatest fast food restaurant in my
opinion it's mcdonald's mcdonald's no i
would agree with you there yeah that i
would agree with you okay i love
mcdonald's i i don't eat it anymore
either of them really but but if but
man
i like wendy's fries better than
mcdonald's fries i just do
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
there's something in the water out on
that island you guys it's possible it's
possible i don't understand uh yeah uh
soup versus salad
um
depends on the soup depends on the salad
and i guess it's just yeah pick one uh
overall i mean i'll probably grab a
salad
yeah bacon versus sausage sausage
tuna versus tuna salad versus egg salad
tuna salad
peanut butter jelly versus grilled
cheese uh grilled cheese oh dude this is
no joke
uh buffalo wings versus mozzie sticks uh
i'll take the sticks
oh okay i will although if it's boneless
wings i'll take the wings i went buffalo
wings yeah if it's boneless i'll take
the wings i i don't like you know what
i'm not even sad we disagree because i
do like mozzie sticks that wasn't a hard
line in the same one
folks what's your favorite trade mine's
the coffee trade so i want to talk to
you about trade coffee i'm a big coffee
guy i love coffee i love espresso i'm
drinking it all the time you can tell by
my attitude anyway trade coffee proud
sponsor of the taste buds podcast
here's why i think trade coffee is
really cool and why you should try it
try it they're going to connect
customers you
to the freshest and best tasting coffee
they've that you've ever made at home
and how they're going to do that because
they're going to partner you with the
country with the country's best craft
roasters okay they're independent
businesses out there from big cities and
small towns okay and trade customers are
going to be able to connect and buy
coffee from these people through this
service makes sense right i love it you
go to a little city you go to a little
town you go to big city go to big town
what do you say hey
we're gonna get a cup of coffee you go
to a place you go look at this this is a
little mom and pop i've never even heard
of what trade's bringing it to you baby
i personally like the dune flavor why
yes i was attracted initially because of
the movie and book dune
but it also just happened to be a
delicious blend and i loved it i also
liked the vida flavor quite a bit
coffee
from trade they're going to send it to
you
in the form of freshly roasted beans
from 60 of the country's
best craft roasters okay
whether your friends call you a coffee
snob or you just know it when coffee
tastes really perfect maybe you just
have a thing that you get and you when
and
trades real coffee experts personally
taste over 450 roasts so they know
exactly what to recommend to you
okay
you're gonna go on the website you're
gonna answer a couple questions real
quick and you're gonna get your own
personalized variety of coffees
delivered fresh to you as often as you
want no gimmicks that's it so right now
trade is offering new subscribers a
total of 30 off your first order plus
free shipping when you go to
drinktrade.com taste buds that's more
than 40 cups of coffee for free
get started by taking the quiz at
drinktrade.com taste buds and let trade
find you a coffee you'll love that's
drinktrade.com
tastebuds for 30 off
sour patch kids versus skittles
give me a skittle really i went sour
patch uh my only problem with this is
this this i'm gonna tell you why because
i love sour patch i can only eat a
certain amount before i'm done where
skittles grape skittles you could put a
[ __ ] jug of them in front of me and
i'll just eat them until i'm i'm like
i'm like winnie the pooh i'm the
opposite yeah i'm the opposite after a
while with skittles i get like
i just get like i don't know i think
it's weird i think
i can i can keep going usually okay all
right donuts versus muffins
uh i'm a donut guy of course you are
yeah
uh
uh froot loops versus cocoa pebbles uh
the pebbles take it for everything for
me yeah
yeah ice cream versus cookies
i'll go i'll go ice cream i'll go ice
cream he took cookies idiot he would
he's passionate about cookies yes she is
yeah he got whooped on that one though
burgers versus tacos uh uh burger i need
a burger i love a taco i love a taco
yeah but we're in the united states
we're in the united states of america i
went tacos yeah but i love a taco all
right yeah apple juice versus orange
juice uh
generally speaking orange juice but i
[ __ ] love apple juice all right i
went apple juice yeah i could i could if
i thought about it a little bit more i
might have ended up on apple things he
said about apple juice you would have
liked it
snickers versus kitkat kitkat really i
don't like what snickers is peanuts
yeah i'm slightly allergic to people
okay all right yeah yeah i don't know
i've never had a shot table snowballs
versus devil dogs
i'm not familiar with snowballs all that
much they're the coconut
well there's a lot going on in a
snowball it's like coconut marshmallow
chocolate graham cracker devil dog yeah
all right we're fault we're we're we're
we're drifting here cheesesteak versus
chicken parm hero cheese stick
we're back yeah we're back french fries
versus onion rings i can't even believe
this one
well he picked onion
[Laughter]
it was nuts kind of a man
[Laughter]
uh
oh wait
snow caps versus raisin nuts why did i i
didn't pick snow caps did i
i don't remember oh well let's skip it i
can't remember lobster roll versus crab
cake
uh i'll probably take crab cake over a
lobster roll i think it's just my man
better to eat fried chicken versus
barbecue ribs
this was a tough one because i love
fried chicken but i was ribs
if i'm i'll tell you what
i'm gonna go ribs because if the menu's
in front of me
unless i'm in a place that's [ __ ]
known for fried chicken right patty b's
right i'm doing ribs every time i agree
i agree
you ready for this one yeah potato chips
versus pretzels what did he pick
pretzels
over potato chips
what are we talking about i don't know
hard like hard pretzels or the the
ballparks no no snack pretzels
you know cardboard like you put in a
ball like you're putting a bow in a bar
you don't want to go too yeah it's
caramel yeah all right
the worst thing ever
put out on a table of snacks yeah
margarita versus martini oh this
[ __ ] on this one oh
he is very particular about his martinis
he's very particular about martinis what
did you pick
i mean i i like fun so i'd probably go
with a margarita yeah of course yeah
yeah yeah two days after that battle
after he said margaritas were for
college kids and trash
he posted a video of himself drinking a
martini unironically feet of clay
unironically just like out having a
lovely evening with a wonderful drink
and ryan sent it to me and was like look
at this
i mean i was
it's sad when you twisted a nice like
[ __ ]
wash away margarita is just fun man
ready for this one yeah coffee versus
tea
i'm a tea guy
i don't even break in my heart i don't
like coffee cheesecake versus chocolate
cake cheesecake wow all right i love
cheesecake chocolate guy
i love cheesecake okay
uh
some of these i'm forgetting what we
picked oh annie anne's versus
cinnabon well he's a pretzel guy
we learned yeah so he went for annie
anne's yeah
can't even come close to a cinnabon
i'm probably going to be honest with you
i'll probably go to auntie really yeah
yeah all right we gotta get back here
buddy ketchup versus mustard
uh you like mustard i'm a mustard i mean
i love ketchup yeah i'll probably go to
ketchup
beach versus pool
you gotta taste give me the pool hold on
you gotta take the fame factor out of it
you got to take out like oh people are
going to recognize me okay i'm thinking
about my pool in my yard yeah you get
you got to think about just the
experience of a beach and the ocean
versus
i would say beach overpool yeah
thank you but my pool
is you know we're back all right we're
back let's do a couple more and then
we'll then we'll get to the battle
keep scrolling pimp
oh ready for this luke skywalker versus
han solo i'm a han solo guy of course
you are buddy what are you talking about
you know what you would pick luke
skywalker i think i think we just and
last but not least de rosa versus the
stefano yeah i mean you know you know
where i stand buddy let's do that again
all right
i like de stefano
i love him yeah he's a pig he's my
favorite pig yeah
i don't i don't want to make it seem
like there's an issue you know what
battle we should have done today look at
this by the way you're here with me
you get a 15 000 result vote wow man
every time i do with sal it's like in
the it's a middling fourth house they
don't even know it's you and me today
they just know they can feel it yeah
they know you know what we should have
done what we should have done sal versus
murr that's what we should have done
today
i gotta tell you though that would have
been great to pit him again or sal
versus distefano why don't i think of
these things yeah damn it
ah
man that's all right we got chicken
first egg what let's [ __ ] let's make
let's make gravy baby all right let's
get busy ready
all right here we go time to be hey
buds
all right you're team chicken i'm t i i
am team chicken uh
i mean i'll i'll open it up by saying
this
steak is j is king i mean it's just
there's no such thing as a chicken house
you know there are places that
specialize in chicken of course but
usually it's a certain type of chicken
it's a it's a fried chicken place like
you said or whatever but steak house
right there i mean it is the staple of
american cuisine
it is the backbone it is everything it
is
it you cannot mess with steak
like i i don't even keep this fair are
you separating eggs from chickens
you're talking about just a prepared
chicken meats i'll tell you what i'll
give you eggs i'll let you bring eggs
into the taste of the foundation of
every meal this is ever made this is how
much i believe in steak wow i'm gonna
let you bring eggs into your argument
and i'm gonna keep mine to just steak
i'm not gonna go into hamburger i'm not
gonna go into cheese steaks i'm not
gonna go into anything like roast beef
i'm gonna keep this as a straight-up
classic that's how strong you feel about
it yeah now all going into the different
cuts of steak what's your perfect
how do when people say how do you want
that cooked what do you say medium rare
medium rare why why medium rare uh
because it tastes the best that way i
like a little blood
i like with the when the meat's pink i
mean anybody that gets anything past the
medium rare to me doesn't understand how
food works okay why because i i i'll
i'll live at the medium
medium is sometimes i'll go medium well
no way i don't like the blood i don't
like
i don't like the blood i don't like to
be reminded i'm eating a sentient
creature and the blood reminds me of
that i understand that like i i could i
could get on board with that uh medium
rare often doesn't have a ton of blood
like it's like you know there's a little
bit
but but medium should never have blood
medium should just straight up medium is
still passable when it's just pink
medium well now you're getting into a
territory where it's like you're dealing
now with with more brown than pink on
the meat and i don't like that's a ruin
that ruins a steak well he's well done
i'm like what are we even talking about
here i have well done yeah i got i like
well done fish i do like well done fish
but um i will say this i've learned i've
learned that chefs steak chefs
hate
hate
medium well
yeah so
they hate medium anytime i order medium
the center is raw it's [ __ ] raw so
i've learned to start ordering medium
medium well and because they hate it so
much they dial it back to like like a
true medium where are you going for your
steaks that this is happening i mean
this has happened to me in the great
steaks house all around the country
i've just learned that to get the steak
i want with just with the pink with the
pink center i i if i don't say medium
well it's always like medium rare are
you a send it back guy
no i'm not so you'll you'll eat that raw
middle or you just won't eat it uh if it
if it's just flat out like [ __ ] like
disrespectful raw then then i'll be like
uh maybe i'll order something else i i i
don't want to send anything back i
always feel like bad about that right or
it's well
i i which i shouldn't
it's tough because nobody wants to be
that guy right that sends the thing you
know that has a problem with everything
that complains about everything nobody
wants to be that person but at the same
time
when something is just wrong and it's
like no guys this was your bad banging
you over the head for 60 bucks too with
it yeah you know i mean that's the thing
it's like
you know
sometimes
i think sometimes it's hard to to to
realize or remember
that for the average person
going out to dinner right that's like
that's like a thing like that's like
they're spending some money they're
making a decision they like you know
what i mean like as a single guy
it doesn't faze me because i don't have
to worry about anybody else right so if
i eat out i eat out that's it like who
cares but like you you got a family and
you're taking the kids out and
everything like you're spending money
and if you're working a regular job you
don't have like you know tons of cash
lying around
and they they [ __ ] the meal up that's
bad sucks dude like so i'd say in that
case absolutely send it back you know
but i also get the other side of it too
where it's like you just don't
you know sometimes a mistake is just a
mistake and
you know i i think it's easy to tell
though carelessness from a mistake sure
it's also got a lot to do with the
demeanor of who your work who you're
dealing with in the restaurant you see
the attitude of the person you're
dealing with the waiter or the waitress
that to me informs a lot of the time
like
this was a mistake versus care this was
just careful a lot of times that works
against me because what i'll do what'll
happen to me is i'll get a waiter or
perhaps uh the staff of a restaurant who
are watching practical jokers and then
they're just excited that you're there
and then right like this has happened
like the manager will come over all
we're big fans oh they'll send over
drink or something like that and then if
your state comes in
poorly done
like i can't send that back like now i'm
like i i don't know i feel like that's
[ __ ] a personal thing you know what i
mean so then you'll see me choke through
a steak that i don't want to eat because
it's you know what if your chicken
wasn't fully done well you get sick
right and like die at that in theory you
know salmonella salmonella
a lot of people i'm not saying to eat
rare chicken everybody that's not what
i'm saying but salmonella is is has to
do with temperature not rawness
because you just got to kill the it dies
at a certain temperature yeah so so you
know that's why they say like you know
if there's blood in a chicken like
cooked chicken it's by the bone it's
fine but you know what i mean but you
would you know if you saw chicken blood
cold out of the out of the package you
would be terrified it would be
disgusting you know what i mean
but how do you feel about the
versatility of chicken
versus
the relative straight road of steak you
could do a chicken parmesan you know
what i mean you do also all the things
that you took away from yourself i guess
it's what i'll always say about every
week food on this show okay you got to
do that because you're not dealing with
much your base is nothing
your base is boring it's bland it needs
to be dressed up chicken you do you
dislike chicken that you take it you
take chicken mcnuggets
babe i'm talking look what you're saying
to me i don't need the babe stuff this
is i don't need it you could save that
for the network this is
okay i don't need that this is what
you're so this is what you just said
yeah chicken mcnugget it couldn't be
more dressed up even if you get like a
one that's not a mcdonald's processed
pink slime one you're you're getting
you're dipping it in a batter and deep
frying it with seasoning whatever dude
i'm talking you take chicken yeah this
is what i mean but when i say your base
has no
weight to it you take chicken straight
out of a package you don't like grilled
chicken
come on
you like grilled chicken i like a good
grill outside of it outside of a salad
where it's doused with a bunch of other
good stuff around it no it's like a walk
man i don't know what to tell you i i
can't argue with you that that you need
that chicken definitely needs the
dressing up a little bit but i will also
say i like steak with steak sauce
you know oh boy
folks i want to talk to you about better
help what's better than help better help
life can be overwhelming as we all know
especially in these turbulent times
we're living in
uh and this podcast is sponsored by
better help which i'm proud to say uh
you know look
we're burdened right now uh you know and
some of us don't even know it symptoms
of burden being burdened and and anxiety
and all these sort of things can include
a lack of motivation they can include
can include feeling helpless or trapped
it it can you could feel detached you
can feel fatigued there's so much more
i've been there so many times myself
i've been burnt out
and it starts in for me it starts in an
emotional place and then it manifests
physically for other people it's the
other way around sometimes it starts in
a physical place and then manifests
emotionally however it's happening it's
something that you should
try to recognize and try to rectify and
that's where better help comes in
they're great at what they do they're
great at helping you pinpoint these
issues and the and the symptoms of these
issues and getting these things fixed
better help is customized online therapy
they're offering video
they're offering phone they're offering
live chat sessions with a therapist so
you don't have to see anyone in person
you don't even have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to trust me
folks is a lifelong therapy guy
that is new and and has been unheard of
for far too long uh this is also much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
always point that out when i talk better
help because that's so key
um and you're gonna get matched up with
a therapist in under 48 hours you can't
beat that they're doing everything right
that the unfortunate
unfortunately the health care industry
has not done right with this they're
making the the the uh experience
expedited they're not charging you an
arm and a leg and they're molding the
session experience to whatever your
preference is so taste buds listeners
you're going to get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp uh when you go to
betterhelp.com tastebuds again
10 off your first month when you go to
betterhelp.com
tastebuds folks let's talk electric
e-bikes
electric e-bikes
they shortened the name but they
certainly didn't shorten the experience
this is an all-in wonderful electric
bike experience i don't know if you've
ever ridden an e-bike i never really did
until i got my electric bike and i got
to tell you i loved it uh these things
are awesome it's got pedal assist okay
which means when you pedal there's a
motor that can assist you so you can
pedal more easily or better pedal faster
or something like that but then you've
also got a throttle so you don't have to
pedal at all what i liked about that
particularly in a city experience is
being able to weave into
a trafficking area if i needed to and
using the throttle to be able to speed
in and merge quickly
and then when you can get back into the
proper bike lane you can pedal and stuff
to me the throttle and the assisted
pedal
that's those are safety features as far
as i'm concerned they're not just
convenience seat features they're there
to help you out and help you ride as
safely as possible um you can also
just ride the bike if you want to you
know nobody's saying you got to get any
assistance if you don't want if you're
one of these toughies hey pedal on your
own they're fine with that uh it was
super fun to ride
uh as a city goer this is something that
could help me
never use my car uh you know when i'm
running at least small errands or going
on uh weekend activities uh you get
enough of a distance in this thing that
you can go a little ways out i mean
you're obviously not gonna go interstate
with it uh but you know what i'm saying
you can you can get some stuff done
socially and just in your daily life uh
with with electric bike with electric
bike not electric bike with a electric
bike it's surprisingly affordable model
starting at just 799 that's way less
than the competition trust me i've
priced it out uh they're adjustable and
customizable customizable and they're
comfortable even for people who don't
don't normally ride bikes uh again take
it from me a sort of lurchy guy
very comfortable ride i loved it it's an
incredibly durable
bike the design is convenient you can
fold it up
it ships free it comes pre-assembled and
you're pre-charged meaning the battery
so you'll be on the road in no time
folks get yourself one of these things
cover up to 45 miles at up to 28 miles
per hour on just a four to six hour
charge it's way more equal eco-friendly
than a car you can explore the great
outdoors or as i said the city
while keeping the air clean anyway look
join the affordable e-bike revolution go
to electricbikes.com
and use the promo code tastebuds for a
free
foldable mountable bike lock with any
bike purchased that's a free bike lock
when you use the code taste buds that's
a free bike lock when you use the code
taste buds at l e c t r i c
e b i k e s dot com
[Music]
wow
you go to peter luger it's like half the
fun of it is that is the stage sauce
terrible steak in that place you don't
like peter lucas i don't like peter
lugers at all and that's why they got
steak sauce on every table because the
steak stinks so who give me a good steak
place in manhattan
uh i mean i'm no snob like i like most
of the steak places in manhattan
i love uh um
the palm it's common you know i'm sure
the strength my favorite is uh is
the one on um
14th street um
oh for god's sakes my brain is [ __ ] okay
14th and 9th we could revisit that i
love the oh sparks is my favorite sparks
is that where the guy in the mafia guy
got shot sparks is awesome castellano
i do not oh old homestead is awesome i
do not like uh sorry peter lugers no
offense i respect the institution oh
it's too late now but i think that i i i
went all the way i don't think you said
it's a horrible place i don't think this
it's just horrible places the steak
stinks
that's what they're there for i think i
will say that lousy i've been to peter
like multiple times in my life and the
wait staff is always [ __ ] dicks to me
so it's like it's all these and not in a
bad way like in an old man like
welcome to peter luke's [ __ ] sit and
be happy or sit and talk that's what i
mean
like for to k like to throw that kind of
weight around
you better be serving up something
pretty fancy and you don't feel them
they're matching no it tastes like to me
that to me it tasted like when my dad
would make a london broil on the grill
and i guess that's not what they want to
hear and i go dad where's the a1
yeah
you don't like a1 i love a1
but when a steak is made right i
wouldn't put it near it
you know what i mean i wouldn't put it
near it dude like like
peter luger steak sauce is gross to me
too it's that barbecue saucy kind of
steak so yeah that has like a sweetness
well yeah when i'm at peter lucas though
that's what i'm looking for that that's
why i'm there like i wouldn't buy peter
lucas on in the store and bring it home
i would use a1 because i do love a good
a1 a1 is a1 i mean it's great in the
firehouse dude we used to buy
jugs of a1 yeah like the milk carton
it's amazing yeah it wants good [ __ ]
let's digress on anyone for a second you
put that on chicken oh i'll put that on
chicken you don't do that on chicken no
no you have you done it yeah i've tried
to i've tried to put a1 on different
like not on it i'll dip it in wait it
doesn't taste right to me without steak
talk to me about
steak dinner a1 sauce baked potato you
start putting that [ __ ] a1 sauce in
the baked potato sopping it up with that
i i sop up a bit of it with the potato
i'm not against that especially the
potatoes got some sour cream on it now
we're
we're banging on all cylinders here but
on a different a meat i i find the only
even a1's big
ad campaign in the 80s
was
uh
uh make it a steak burger okay
that was a big thing they did where they
would have a guy the dad making the
hamburgers on the grill and then they
would pour the a1 sauce on it and they
would say now it's a steak burger and
that was going to elevate your burger
experience and i tried that a couple
times i hate it the way it tasted even
on ground beef i didn't think it tasted
right can i ask you a question yeah
back it up a little bit here what is a
one sauce what the [ __ ] is going on in
there pimp can we get the recipe for a1
the ingredients is it like vinegar and
there's definitely a heavy vinegar yeah
you can taste it i might start making my
own because the store-bought one has has
a decent amount of sugar in it
and i'm trying to stay away from sugar
right now because i'm trying to drop
weight should call it j.o sauce
that's you should like joe's well
they're a one you be joe zero but you
call it jl's i might call it j one
because
zero comes from one
j yeah but it's also a great jerk off
joke you don't think that that's uh like
a home run j.o sauce look at that dude
raisin paste
that's the secret ingredient yeah see
the corn syrup is the best part crushed
orange puree diced garlic and onion
spice
spice what the [ __ ] does that mean
that's so
that's like star wars [ __ ] like that's
the castle
tomato puree i can find raisin paste is
where you're going to run into some
trouble i think
what finding it around these parts i
mean i now you're in new york city bro
you could find raisin paste i've never
even heard of that no but we live in the
midst of a cultural melting pot you're
gonna find raisins all right
uh all i re and then it says
uh but the the person listing these
ingredients is all i really taste is
worcestershire and ketchup uh i have
made steak sauce and my base is always a
ketchup
and then i go in with the worcestershire
and i build from there sometimes some
soy goes in
um
you know so you definitely a bit of
vinegar
but it never tastes as good as a1 it's
just something about a1 about a1
but let's get back to your weak chicken
okay hold on one second because i i want
to approach it from a different angle
because i
feel a guilt
eating steak
that i don't feel eating chicken
why
i think it's because i've met cows and
i've met chickens and cows
seem more vaguely
peopleish to me
than chickens does that make sense sure
and
i've never met a cow that i haven't
really really liked to meet whereas
chickens just kind of run around
chickens are awful
that's another way to play they're
they're pretty awful that that whole
strain of bird
i'm not a fan
okay that type of bird yeah any barnyard
birds
i don't like any of them uh once we get
into the duck now we're talking guy you
won't eat duck you got a classy animal
there you can't eat ducks not candy duck
because they're too cute you mean
they're my grandmother's favorite animal
and they're too cute uh i ate the [ __ ]
out of duck yeah
duck but i heard ducks are very mean
they'll bite you i've known good ducks
and bad ducks i grew up in a lot of
ponds there's a lot of ponds on staten
island
but a cow though every time i eat a
steak i can't
separate
i i have something in my head that's
very tough it's like eating horse
which people do do i know like it's it's
even even pork has gone that way for me
because now they're saying that like
pigs are like the third most intelligent
animal on the planet or some [ __ ] like
that and like and like there's their
meat pork pig skin
is the closest thing to human skin in
the animal kingdom and all right don't
ruin people pork meat is the closest
thing to human meat oh really so
you want to eat human meat a little bit
no i'm sorry it makes me do the opposite
not want to eat pigment yeah instead of
taking the negative of not wanting to
eat pig start looking at the positive
glasses have full maybe you want to eat
human
you know there's there's a that's the
other way to go on that one to joey
roses i think
i think cannibals are
universally like um you know shunned i
don't think anybody's like opening the
doors for cat i would love to see
like a social like justice movement for
cannibals pick up because that would
that would be wild
they deserve a voice i guarantee there
is one somewhere yeah that would be
right well well listen
for uh all your [ __ ] about the cows
q well i didn't i don't know
i don't know compassion for for the
suffering of these animals is [ __ ]
no here's why i'm calling it [ __ ]
yeah chickens dream when they sleep yeah
what do you think of that i think it's
hard your [ __ ] nuggets yeah all right
chickens have strong color vision they
have great memories and can recognize
over a hundred faces wow the problem is
they can't express it in any way like a
cow could lick you and you'd be like
maybe he likes me a chicken is gonna
peck your leg
like that might be the chicken's way of
saying hey well yeah yeah but you see
those videos of like cows when they're
like let out of you know how like their
lives are horrible because they're in
these [ __ ] like houses and then they
let them out on grass once a year and
they start acting like puppies like you
only see one video of a cow acting like
a puppy before you're like i
i can't have you guys ever seen the
videos where the cows run to any sort of
live music no really they love music
so here's a guy playing a what is that a
trombone oh look at that he's just in a
field playing a trombone yeah here they
come
and there's hundreds of these videos
it's so fun cows make best friends like
cows cows like it's showing that they
have social constructs and they make
good friends with each other look at
these guys they're loving the music
they're all i can't
so you know all right so then all right
they just listen
look at that i mean
how am i they're music fans
all
right they like fu manchu like if you
played foo manchu they'd be [ __ ]
right there with you man
that's it then no more steak for you
you're done you're out
i think i i don't want to see it on that
grill no no i got a nice grill i do have
a nice girl i think that i don't think
i'm there yet but i think i'm headed
because it's goddamn delicious well
because like but now i can't eat even a
hamburger without feeling guilty
i can for some reason with chicken
and i shouldn't but i do so what do you
want i'm i'm i'm a flow but i think any
one of us when we're around an animal
i'm sorry there's no way i'm ever going
to look at a pig and start to feel bad
they're just so disgusting
they're so disgusting we shouldn't be
eating chickens either because you know
what they do you ever watch the videos
of like
how they
how they take care of the male chickens
like what they do because male chickens
are basically useless
so
they have conveyor belts
of baby chicks
it's a full-on white factory people in
like the gear and the gloves and it's
just conveyor belts of cute chicks
little yellow chicks and they check them
and if they're a male they put them on
one conveyor belt if they're female they
put them on another convenient and the
females are sent to
the life of a female chicken which is
laying eggs and and
being that the males are sent
to a [ __ ] grinder that grinds them up
instantly so they don't feel pain but it
just it's just a conveyor belt cheap
cheap cheap
and they're gone stop they're gone it's
the craziest way why are the male
chickens useless we could eat the male
chickens no they're roosters nobody's
gonna [ __ ] eat a rooster oh you can't
eat roosters yeah well the people don't
this is it this is cute [ __ ] look at
this
and you're like is that dead chicks yeah
well i thought they went into a glass no
that's not i don't know what that new
horror is i know the grinder is the
craziest thing um all right we're going
to bum everybody out well yeah we should
no
because we're going to go back to eating
chicken next week
yeah but you shouldn't feel good
chicken and steak
i know i [ __ ] ate both and i feel
horrible about it i made short ribs
today and a chicken piccata
no i don't want to watch this you don't
see anything this is too sad for this
you don't see anything like they just
disappear they're just gone it's crazy
this is too sad for this yeah it's not
look at that [ __ ] thing that looks
like that's like batman type stuff yeah
so i mean you know
so right i'm actually
i'm defeating my own argument here
because like and now i don't want to eat
chicken either but like i can't i i
can't eat cow without feeling like a
piece of [ __ ]
well this isn't helping but i mean the
rooster is i guess a useless animal now
that you've already waked you up in the
morning yeah but they have one and it
impregnates
everything
it's just we live in it's hard to
[ __ ] stomach and this is this is
where i'm getting to the point where i'm
i i was vegetarian for a year i went i
did it for a year how'd it go i put on
like 25 pounds because i was just eating
pasta all the [ __ ] time
yeah i mean it's it's brutal when you
cut out the meat it's so i try to do it
at times and i'm like it's literally
healthier right now for me to eat turkey
with this meal
than whatever i'm substituting the
turkey with let me ask you something
wait a second though before you do put a
pin in the question okay
why can't we eat rooster they used to
eat rooster i don't understand can you
click on that article pimp
oh i think they're saying because the
roosters are necessary to make more
chicken that you don't eat the roosters
a lot of people do eat roosters
it is it is not common in american homes
for people to eat roosters unless of
course they are raising their own meat
so they q so then why would they kill
the roosters why don't they just let
them grow up and we use them for food
because the cost of raising them
probably isn't with with the chicken you
get the eggs you get the the double
output
okay you're getting profit on all sides
with the rooster like you're just
raising it feeding it until it's ready
to go be eaten raising a female chicken
is easier and cheaper
you're right yeah more economical for
large-scale poultry breeders and poultry
farms to produce and sell hen meat
than rooster meat
wow
does a rooster taste different
it can't right yeah oh no rooster meat
is tough and chewy it tastes different
requires a longer cooking time to broil
the chicken broiler chickens are more
popular tender and easier to cook oh wow
oof all right
so so what was your question well my
thing is like this if i went on a date
with a girl and i mentioned some of the
stuff that i just said to you and this
is why i know you you you know you're
giving you try to give yourself this
reputation as being like
you you not a kind per i don't know you
try to paint yourself as like this no no
i think i'm a very i think i'm a very
kind person i think you are i but i do
think a sour person i have a i have a
yeah i have a jagged
aspect and i'm going to tell you why i i
don't agree with that and this is why
maybe like i because you know i meet a
lot of people i don't take them like i
take like i took to you right because
i saw on your face when i was describing
the chicken's plight
i saw it you were your heart was
breaking for the chicken yeah it's
horrible so if you were on a date right
and i was thinking like if i was on a
date with a girl and i mentioned that to
them and they were like i don't give a
[ __ ] i like chicken like
that's it right like you just you at
least need the guilt you're on a date
with the joker jesus christ
what psycho would you fake it and then
just run home any chicken anyway she's
not being a hypocrite i am because i
know this and it makes me sick to my
stomach it makes me feel guilty but like
you just pointed out you were like you
want some chicken i was like dana gold
had the had the best joke about this he
had the best joke about this
he goes i was out to dinner with a
vegetarian and the vegetarian's like oh
she ate meat and he's like yep and she's
and then she was like so you yield his
steak and he goes right again
and she goes but you wouldn't want to
kill a cow and he goes nailed it
and he goes uh everything doesn't have
to be taken back to the point of being
awful yeah i love my brother i don't
want to see my parents [ __ ]
that's pretty great that's a pretty
great justification and argument for it
it's like yeah there's obviously an
unpleasant sign to outside yeah to a lot
of things we enjoy uh you know i i get i
get why the
term
uh you know humane
slaughter
uh is is an oxymoron and i get why
people have issues with that
um but i do think that as people who
creatures who have incisors for a reason
yeah uh
part of the food chain yeah
food chain is a valid thing to believe
in
i think that there are plenty of
pro-meat arguments to be made for your
health and all these other things
and there are plenty of
anti-made arguments to be made the point
is is there's enough evidence out there
that if you're somebody who chooses to
eat meat it's pretty well supported and
justified
um
so so my point is is
i think there's a proper way to do it
and sure you know which is why i guess
you know we try to buy the meat with the
right sticker on it that says you try
yeah you try to humanely raised and all
that stuff and it's like like i said
before like my cats they have like a
duck pate
which is not as expensive as fancy as it
sounds and i don't mind feeding them
that because i'm like well they're
[ __ ] cats
like that's what they should be eating
like they'd be down at clove lake which
is like on staten island eating ducks
right so i don't feel bad about that
right well and you know but a cow i mean
how many videos are there of them
listening to music is that a thing so
many it's a whole genre oh i don't know
man i don't know
i might have just eaten the last cow all
over that was that was that was tough to
see that was tough to see
me that have set me worse than the
chicken it is it is and i don't know why
the one thing about steak is i feel like
it's the most choked on food no
it is it i've seen more people choking i
know a guy that just died because he
choked on steak i swear to god two weeks
ago what yeah i had to give the heimlich
to check
oh yeah that's right the heimlich the
chassis choked on steak at his house
yeah it was just me and him
i'm afraid to steak just because of that
he was eating steak what time of day was
it by the way we were recording a
podcast all day
but it's one of those things it's like
it almost killed him i don't have my
[ __ ] together at all
uh i almost died i could die
i always died as a kid i choked on steak
and my grandfather gave me the heimlick
but i almost choked to death yeah you
gotta be careful you gotta you know well
now we're learning that people don't
choke on chicken
um i've never heard of that people choke
the chicken hey
we're back to comedy here on taste buds
well i'll i'll go back
i'll i'll use that to to go with my
closing arguments which are you know
chicken is always
as a euphemism or used in you know in
the public discourse it's always gross
it's always like choked chicken
you know it's like it's like steak
like you know we got beef that's like
troublesome well
it's it's negative but it's not gross
there's an honor there's an honor
there's an honor to beef there's an
honor to having beef there's an honor
like don't have a cow it's like it's not
that bad you know uh holy cow whatever i
feel like you're really stressing on
this
picturing choking the chicken
neck
i think i have a point but uh
whatever yeah still thinking about those
things listening to that [ __ ] music
you're thinking about you're thinking
about cows listening to danny elfman's
music for a darkened theater and loving
it and and it's it's hard to get past it
it is
i'm not saying like i'm not using it i'm
not wielding it against you i'm inviting
you into the struggle that i have
every single time i eat beef well look
the lesson here is the lesson here is is
you know go to mcdonald's it's funny
mcdonald's is gonna come full circle and
become the place everybody loves again
because people are gonna eventually go
there's barely a stitch of meat in that
[ __ ]
but i wanna eat it so i can feel like i
ate a burger and you're gonna go there
and eat the best fake meat you've ever
had in your life i'm down for that i'll
eat fake meat man yeah i had fake
chorizo the other day like um what's
that [ __ ] that people at tofu chorizo it
was i
for the life of me i couldn't tell it
wasn't chorizo it was [ __ ] awesome
i'm not a fan of chorizo and for that
reason yeah chorizo to me has always
just taste i don't hate it okay but
usually theresa to me literally just
tastes like seasoning on stuff yeah you
know what i mean yeah that's why it
worked like whereas other sausage has
yeah i had italian sausage for lunch
today and it's just got
it's great it's amazing dude it's
amazing and that's cow as well right
oh it's like cow and pork and that's
just pork
thai sausage is just pork
unless you buy you have to it usually
will specify that if it's a beef sauce i
mean maybe there's some beef in there i
don't think so
sausage is almost always pork unless it
says chicken okay i've never even really
heard of beef sausage i've heard of beef
hot dogs
all beef hot dogs and like or like beef
not worst or whatever but like i've
never seen like a beef based italian
sausage
you know pork is really pork is the
thing yeah
let's go
in a sausage oh yeah that you slice you
know you get the old guys and the wife
peters and they sit in there and they're
80 years old and it comes in the casing
and it's hard heart italian sausage what
is the white stuff in it
i think it's just fat
gristle
i don't think it's gristle because
gristle is hard i think it's just fat
like you know
when you the kind of cut of pork that
you're grinding up to make sausage i've
had sausage made for me like on the spot
oh
no
from pork cuts oh jesus christ i didn't
shoot a cow in the head or poor pig in
the head then right i didn't watch a
slaughter i'm just saying like
like i've i've gone to like certain like
um uh butchers that are like we do the
sausage here okay
or you'll say i want ground pork here's
a better example i want ground pork to
make meatballs sure see they'll grind it
for you oh they put in that thing that
people so the stuffed yeah then when the
stuff they grind you know there's fat in
it so like when they grind it you get
you get a combination of
pink pink and white the white is the fat
part and the pink part is the meat
saying it's mold i don't know
come on now what
the white pep no that's white powder on
oh that's talking about like a heart
like a dry sausage
a chip of bone i don't know it's not
there's no real answer if you buy
italian are you talking about salami
type sauce are you talking about sausage
like
italian like hot italian sausage yeah
that's fat yeah cause you're taking like
a fatty piece of pork and you're
grinding it up
i don't know man i think we should just
stop eating cows and chickens
i like pork till the cows come home to
listen to music
you know what i mean i don't care
but i mean honestly the only reason i
even deal with the chicken is because of
the unhealthiness of the cow
you know what i mean like you have no
use for chicken
fried chicken i love i love fried
chicken yeah if it's done right done
right kfc is my jump off i love it you
love kfc i love popeyes and i do okay
and i love certain places you know like
i love i love soul food like fried
chicken is great okay um
i love a chicken nugget
chicken fingers i could care less if i
ever came across one for the rest of my
life
uh
baked chicken is a wonderful meal but
turkey
has it beat hands down you know like a
big chick when i get excited about baked
chicken i'm excited about the meal that
surrounds that i'm not excited about the
chicken i'm excited about the chicken
meeting the stuffing meaning the mashed
potatoes yeah yeah it's the whole thing
so you could tell me dude we're just
gonna do baked turkey and i'll be just
as happy there i'll be just as happy
okay um
so you know you tell me hey dude you
can't really have chicken anymore you're
fine
i'll find something else to put my main
go to a chicken is for salad okay
grilled chicken salad you know but like
and then like this you know the chicken
piccata i served today
delicious
it wasn't bad yeah it's pretty good but
like once in a while i get a hankering
for something like that and i make it
and then usually by
you know i don't even really want the
leftovers i'm like yeah i'm over it you
know what i mean like pork is king i
mean let's be honest i'm not i'm not the
biggest pork fan in the world i'm
fascinated by the the pig
the pig
i'm
it is the only
animal and before you say i'm wrong
which most people do when i say this
sentence so i'm assuming you might say
this too
maybe you won't i don't know i'm just
saying this is i'm basing that what i'm
saying i'm basically me telling you that
okay on what people have said to me
before
before you say i'm wrong yeah just think
about that okay think about what i'm
saying and i'll give you that the pig is
the only animal that produces several
different tasting
types of meats
it is the only animal the cow produces
one thing cuts of steak
sides of beef of different kinds
there's a slight variation in flavor
given the fat content
uh or or slight variation and tenderness
given on where the cut is taken
but steak pretty much tastes like steak
there's a very common flavor in all
steak and then you grind up that steak
and you make hamburgers and you know in
the process of doing that the flavor is
altered a bit but a hamburger is not
coming out of a cow
uh
chicken is chicken
it tastes like chicken that's it
pork walk me through the different porks
ham
entirely different ball game than bacon
but isn't that just like the preparation
and the cooking some of it is obviously
right but you put a you put a pork loin
next to a rib
and it's you're dealing with just two
different it's just two different i mean
i don't know people go nuts on you with
this opinion you know people say it's
not true but i'm telling you it's true
you put
you put any chicken-based lunch meat
right yeah tastes like chicken here's
okay so let's say it is something to do
with the process of it right sure like a
buffalo chicken right still tastes like
chicken you could never make something
that tasted like ham out of a piece of
chicken you could never make something
that tasted like ham out of a piece of
cow
but you can make something that tastes
like ham out of a pig you can make
something that tastes like bacon out of
a pig yeah you can make something that
tastes like sausage out of a pig and
then you have pork chops pork loin pork
ribs and all of those things in and of
themselves vary pretty greatly in flavor
there's a reason why
and i got schooled on this by our fans
and the fans you guys were 100 right
because i put it to the test afterwards
there's a reason why
i'm a believer now i've seen the light
you can put spare ribs next to pulled
pork and feel like you're eating two
different things that's for sure there's
a reason for that you put you put um
brisket next to a a rib yeah a beef rib
you're like i mean a lot of beef today
you know what i mean yeah yeah i i don't
disagree with you i'm not gonna it's a
fascinating animal dude pig's feet
no you lost me no it's i mean whether
you like it or not it's fine but i'm
saying i mean you know you could start
slicing up all that just sure sure sure
but i'm just chicken's feet i mean you
know they people chicken feet
i heard people eat the eyes i've heard
people eat the eyes too like when you
and it was the most it was just
disgusting it didn't really it was more
about the texture liquidy
it was jelly like jelly liquidy yeah
i got soup at a chinese place in town
here it's right around the corner it's a
really good spot i can't remember the
name of it but it had a chicken foot in
it
and i was actually kind of excited i was
like oh wow i got a foot like i want to
try this because i've heard of it i
really didn't like it it was gross oh
god yeah but the soup was good though
otherwise
all right all right i think you're going
to win this one well we were going to
like you're right steak has a crown and
a throne in the united states that i
think uh is gonna be tough to beat
well according to spencer you can have
chicken a thousand different ways but
there's only one way to make a steak
i i don't know that i agree with that i
don't agree with that either there's
nothing extraordinary about a chicken
but you can do a lot more with it
very much like my boyfriend's crooked
penis all right okay that's a potential
winner
just went out deal with 15 members of my
family choices were chicken salmon and
steak two people chose salmon the rest
got steak not one order of chicken
everybody across the world loves chicken
you don't go to mcdonald's and ask for a
mixed steak witch do you
i would if they hadn't got a hamburger
yeah
their cornerstone of their thing is
beef how is this not a landslide
somebody wrote okay yeah my mom calls me
a caveman because i tear up a good steak
any day at any time
uh chicken is way more versatile
i would agree with that i i think that
you could do a lot more what you're
saying is a weakness of a chicken how it
you need all the accoutrements to make
it nice i think is the strength of the
chicken because you could really go in a
lot of different ways but i mean i mean
you mentioned chicken parm yeah okay
i'll mention country fried steak boom
okay you know or chicken fried steak
there there there's th those are the two
two versions of the same type of
approach to a meat right
doesn't matter which one is better
chicken marsala
chicken marsala you but you i mean
honestly if you want to get dark veal
marsala is really where it's at you know
let's not go down let's not let's
we've just got people my point is is
every chicken dish that you love in the
italian restaurant yeah it started with
veal and and if you're going based on
flavor the veal version of it is way
better okay the chicken parm can't mess
with veal parm it can't even i don't
know man i can't eat veal at all no i'm
not saying cut the ethics out you're
right you're right i'm just saying you
can't i mean look i'm a hypocrite in a
million ways so if you know i'll
probably eat veal again in my life but
yeah i i had to walk away from the aisle
of it the other way like i was turning
like robin williams walking away from an
eight ball in 82
yeah in the supermarket the other day i
think joe is definitely arguing steak so
my here my vote goes to chicken what a
dildo
you know what
i almost want to give that the win if
you narrow down the absolute best
chicken dish you'll find it
still falls to top two or three steak
cuts
yeah chicken is more accessible and
healthy
uh chicken tenders nuggets fingers wings
fried grilled baked versus steak red or
burnt or with or without bone i think
that's the winner that's very funny
uh all right folks follow our winner at
clutch
cliff
clutch cliff
uh on twitter oh there's me and let's go
to the poll that's awesome colonel
sanders that's great
that's great there it is i love it
it's hilarious all right let's see we
got here
we are at
sixteen thousand votes that's whole
healthy number
all right almost seventeen thousand yeah
stay foreign 56.7 to 43.3 stake is the
winner wow yeah beautiful
folks glad i could help your your uh
thanks for being here i feel like these
i i don't know that people are gonna
want me back on because really the crux
of this show is you two tearing into
each other and i
i don't know that well
i don't know that i that that's let me
tell you first of all don't you ever
talk about yourself like that again not
in my not on my watch not on your couch
yeah and i want you on all right but i
will tell you something the episode
that's going out tomorrow
pimp has already told me
appears that sal and i are
legitimately fighting it really
uh i don't remember what was said
because i was drunk through the entire
episode very nice uh so is he so is okay
we're with burke ricer it's a second
part to overcrowd oh husband doing he's
good good um so that comes out tomorrow
well guys not tomorrow watching this
that it's already been out sure yeah but
my point is as we're recording this
tomorrow is monday and it's coming out
so they will welcome the nice calm
soothing
break with you
before it gets back into madness again
and we'll probably have to actually
record one or two more apps with another
guest host anyway okay so i'll bring
somebody in who's a real prick that i
can scream at and you know
yeah you know nice get tim dillon in
here where's tim
we should get tim dillon on the show
that'd be great yeah that would be an
awesome one
uh
i hope to see you soon come to joey
roses in new york city on the march and
the merch go to salvolcanocomedy.com and
buy some taste buds merch i still love
you buddy love you bud taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to the mic i'm talking
taste buds